qu'est ce que je fais dans la vie je
serais incapable de dire ce que je fais
concrètement parce que ça change un peu
tous les jours
[Musique]
la même eau
j'ai participé aux gens en 2016 c'est
vrai que c'était assez indescriptible
comme moment tout était exagérée et
surprenant quand on a 16 ans et quand on
part à rio à défendre les couleurs de
son pays c'est si c'est impressionnant
c'est déstabilisant même parfois mais
voilà j'ai décidé moi d'arrêter la
compétition pour créer mes propres
recherches
[Musique]
non
une course bah je fais partie des
courses les plus difficiles au monde
chez les nageurs c'est une course qui
rassemble entre une vingtaine et une
trentaine de nageurs chaque année moi
l'idée c'est d'être le premier athlète
handisport à participer à la santa fe
corp honda en une journée je pense
m'être entre 15 et 18 heures pour faire
cette course voilà ça va pas être facile
souvent on dit mais qu'est ce que tu
arrives pas à faire est en fait il n'y a
pas beaucoup de choses qui n'arrivent
pas à faire peut-être fermer les boutons
d'une chemise ça reste encore un peu
compliqué mais c'est vrai que j'aime
bien dire que je j'arrive à tout faire
mais pas comme les autres on s'en fout
du chemin qu'on utilise le plus
important c'est la finalité c'est
d'avoir réussi à manger réussi à faire à
manger prendre sa douche sous sol etc
[Musique]